Speaker 1: We don't want to allow that to
happen.
Donald Trump's Jewish allies are begging him,
begging him to condemn Kanye West and Trump
is reportedly refusing.
There's a very good article in Rolling Stone.
Trump's Jewish allies are begging him to condemn
Kanye.
He's refusing.
Prominent Jewish and human rights leaders
are circulating a letter asking the former
president to distance himself from Kanye West
and Nick Fuentes.
They were the people that had the dinner with
Trump the other day.
A Trump adviser responds.
I've seen it and I do not care.
I encourage you to read the entire article.
There's a couple different things that are
important to talk about here.
Number one, it is appalling, appalling that
Trump still has Jewish friends.
That in and of itself doesn't make any sense
whatsoever.
Oh, but David, sir, the his his daughter converted
to Judaism and his grandkids.
None of that.
This is not about that.
It's not even really about Trump's personal
beliefs about Jews, although.
Sure.
I mean, I think we kind of have a sense of
what they are, but it's about the factions
that Trump gives credibility to by not denouncing
or condemning.
Now, to really understand a lot of the entire
Jewish Republican thing, this is as good an
opportunity as any to remind folks in the
audience that support for Israel in the vague
way that evangelical Christians, quote, support
Israel and support for American Jews, could
not possibly be more dramatically different
things.
Right wing support for Israel is primarily
based in evangelicals who believe for biblical
reasons that Jews running Israel is a step
towards the return of Jesus Christ.
Now I know some of you will say, and I'm realizing
I don't have my headphones on and I'm going
to need it for the next segment.
I'm just going to put it on while we chat.
There are people who will say, Oh, but David,
these folks love Israel.
They just they love, love, love Israel.
They love it not because of any concern for
anti-Semitism or anti-Jewish discrimination
or whatever the case may be.
They love it because they see it as a path
to bringing back Jesus.
That's what it is.
American Jews have completely different beliefs
and ideas, etc., etc.
And just because you see a right winger, a
Republican, kowtowing to Israel in the particular
sense that evangelical Christians like it
doesn't mean that they are supportive of American
Jews or even understand, never mind, are going
to fight against anti-Semitism.
So that's number one.
Unfortunately, some Republican Jews ignore
that and they throw in support with Republican
candidates.
Fortunately, it's relatively few because American
Jews are one of the most left wing voting
blocs in the country American Jews, black
folks, two of the most left wing voting groups.
Trump also has black allies.
So it's not completely incredible that he
has Jewish allies as well, even though, you
know, it doesn't really make any sense based
on policy.
But the most important aspect of this to understand
is Trump sees people as objects, tools, or
a means to an end.
And we saw when those folks are no longer
useful to him, he dumps them, flushes them
10 to 15 times.
And unfortunately, there are certain people
that don't get this and they get tricked.
And we're seeing it now once again with Jewish
voters.
But it seems this may be the end of the line
for Trump's Jewish supporters.
We'll see.
There will always be some.